hello my name is sharon meeks
and uh i come from a hard life
but i'm grateful today i've been in
these streets since i was 13 years old
i've been molested by a blue van with 18
guys took me in the alley and i thought
they was going to kill me but by the
grace of god
i live not only that
car accident i had 72 stitches through
my face
and i still got a complex glass went in
my eye i lost my eyesight
and it's hard out here i'm living in a
tent
and i my family really they don't
understand but i don't want to live with
them i got a niece
she's 12 years old do you know my name
is the only name she can say she's
artistic she'll live
just like me and i'm grateful
i've met good people and i've met bad
people
i have a tent i keep hygiene and yes
i drink and stuff and i'll give anybody
anything you ain't got to steal from me
and it hurts my feelings
and to be honest with you i'm tired of
being in these streets i'm
so tired i
i can't see out of this eye behind that
and these scars and stuff really really
bother me
sometimes i'll be willing to give up but
i do break
uh
last few days i didn't lost some close
friends of mine
and i'm just seeing how they going and
any day it could be me
and i really want to change my life
i just don't know how
man i'm just emotional right now i just
lost my mother
and she you know she she tried to make
up for what i went through with her
she bought me a mother and daughter ring
both our birth signs
and mother and daughter i pondered to
the opening
she bought me a gold chain with a heart
with an applying that to the dope man
she asked me she said baby wear your
stuff i said at home
she never asked me again it took me 11
years
to tell my mother the truth what i did
and she said sharon i forgave you a long
time ago
she said i know things you think i don't
know she said now you got to forgive
yourself
i had an attitude till i understand what
she said i got to stop
blaming the world because i'm grown now
i can make my own choice
i sabotage this in myself you know kids
love me i don't have any children and my
feelings was hurt i couldn't hold them
and i see women with babies and i don't
understand why they don't love them
but guess what kids everywhere love me
and i'm grateful for that too
a couple of them ran away to my friend
who was a dope man
he sent him to me because he knew i
would take care of
the first one she told everybody she was
18 but she told me she was 15 in
foster care i let her stay with me a
couple of days
and i called the people to come and get
her she ran away again with another the
third time
another and all of a sudden i'm coming
about the apartment i was living in with
a friend
and police officer went up on me he was
the sergeant
and i said oh lord he got out the car he
said sharon meeks
and i was on parody and i knew i had a
a warrant he said i know they call you
brenda
he said i know you're on parole he said
that ain't what i came for
he said there's something special about
you because
foster care want to help you and i'm
looking he said
miss mix if i got to go in my pockets
and pay for you to go in the program
i would he said because you got a gift
and it scared me i run away
from good things i run all the time
i'm sitting up there and a little boy's
in front of me everybody's saying green
i said well they said look in front of
you when i looked it was like he
couldn't have been no more than six or
seven little mexican but
when i made eye contact he said hi i
said hi
he said i love you and when he started
walking to me his
mother called him the daddy said leave
him alone
that baby walked up and grabbed my hand
stood up man church people came out of
everywhere it's a thousand people on
this street what i mean
the baby wouldn't let my hand go people
said
that god loves me if i need help i can
call this place again
the baby said please call us if you need
it
i said okay i'ma go he said please get
off this corner i was on st
junior and i was selling weed and stuff
i bend down gave him a hug and i left
but when i went to my motel i ate a
piece of chicken
picked up a pipe and hit it
30 minutes later i cried myself to sleep
everywhere i go kids love me i love them
animals love me but half the time i
don't feel like i'm worthy of it
and i know i should be stronger but i
just fall because
my daddy didn't want me
my mother mistreated me but she tried to
make up but thank god
my brothers and him let me i
thank god for mark for allowing me to
tell my story and i'm not ashamed of it
i was at one time
and like my mother said i finally i got
to forgive myself and stop
blaming the world cause i've grown
and i made my own choices
it's hard being out here they
going in people's tent they molested
three weeks ago they molested a 16 year
old little boy
finally somebody called by the time the
police got there
when they bought that baby out of that
chin he was
bloody from head to toe they looked at
that camera
man so many guys were in that tent
and molested this little boy and they
called themselves
gang members and stuff 16 years old
and one [ __ ] excuse my language one guy
had the nurse to say
well he out here he put himself in that
position i said he's 16.
he probably ran away probably just
getting high to get away
that don't mean he deserved it that
they got so much going on out here
so much your closest friends is the ones
who will get you
i call them my friends you know they
can't be my friend
because see you can only do to me what i
allow you
and now i got to start treating myself
right
and eventually i will but i'm 64 years
old
i'm telling you i've been in these
streets since i was 13.
and i thank god i'm living
i'm just saying
if you story is half as mine
don't do yourself don't thank you
nothing
prey on it put your head up
because you ain't hurting them you
hurting yourself
many times i lay in that tent and i cry
you have no idea how tired i am
i just don't know how to change i mean
i've been doing this
since i was 13 to medications
and i don't i want to change so bad
people didn't try to help me put me in
hotels and stuff
i don't go like i said i didn't think i
was worth
even though i know i am
even though i don't know how i got to
put my strength in and i might
like i say you got to forgive yourself
you don't know how many times i've been
raped beated
jumped on food stamp cards taken
people said grants i would call the
police i said no
i'll go and get another card whatever
but i thank god i'm still living
november the fire people was giving away
backpacks and stuff i went there
and this lady walked up to me she was a
white woman
she said what's your name and i told her
she said can i talk to you i said yeah
she said you got a beautiful smile but i
see so much sadness in your eyes
i said you would be too you've been in
these streets and you're homeless and
you can't get no help
and she asked me could she see how i
live so i showed her my tent
took pictures and did everything and i
started crying each other
the next day my plane nephew ran up
there and said i figured out
i saw you on tv i said tv they said you
was on channel 4 news and you
they said man you when you put it down
i said the news they said you didn't
know he was on the news i said no
and he said you ought to sue her i said
sue her
for what two months later
i was got my ssi people started wanting
to help me
and if it wasn't for that woman put me
on the channel four news nobody would
have reached out and
touched me and you taught my sue her
tell me she's the reason i'm in a
position that i'm moving up now
and want to change i better think about
what y'all say and do what good people
come in your life
see they came in mind and i sabotaged it
because i didn't think i was
worthy to do nothing good like that
police officer that sheriff's
he wanted to pay to put me in the
program because he said i got a gift
and it's something special about me man
i
never dreamed that would happen to me
so don't listen to dumbness
because they're the only dig you deeper
i
walk down the same street and fall in
the same hole
now i'm gonna walk around that hole
cause i'm tired of falling
i don't know who she is i ain't seen her
since
but i want to thank god for meeting that
woman
i want to thank god for meeting mark
my mother's gone now and i want to thank
god for
catching on when she said forgive
yourself
can't blame the world got a choice
and i choose to do better i don't know
how but i'ma do it
and i'm not ashamed of the things that
happened to me because it happened
and it made me stronger and
very strong i'm coming out that tent
y'all
i'm coming out of that chat you can
believe that
oh and i couldn't have operation on my
eye you know i'm blind in this side
because
glass went through here in that car
accident but it hit my nerve
and they go do surgery they say they
gotta have three but they guarantee me
i'll see you again
that's gonna be so beautiful i wear
shades all the time i tell you all this
i'm ashamed but guess what i'm living
and at 64 i look good yes you do
thank you thank you very much
you are too
that was so sweet though that was
beautiful